ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد تسريحات
المفاجاه للرئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد
شياع السوداني ادت لاثاره المزيد من الجدل
بعد تاييده بقاء القوات الاجنبيه وتحديدا
الامريكيه في العراق لاجل غير مسمم محمد
شريعه السوداني اكد لصاحبته
بقاء القوات الامريكيه في العراق مهم
لمساعده الجيش العراقي
وبالتالي فان القوات الامنيه العراقيه
ستكون بحاجه للدعم الامريكي العسكري
والاستخباراتيه وتحديدا للطائرات المصيره
المتطوره التي تملكها القوات الامريكيه
الاستهدافهم مواقع داعش وفقا مراقبين في
السودان سيسعى لبناء علاقات جنسيه مع
وسنطان في المرحله القادمه ولكنه سيحافظ
في نفس الوقت على علاقه مع طهران جدا
لجميلها في مساندته لتقديده منصبه عبر دعم
كتل الاطار التنسيقي له ومع الجدل الذي
اثارته تصريحات السوداني فان البعض يرى
انها وضعت حكومته في مرمى الانتقادات مع
موقف الاطار التنسيقي الرافضي لتواجد اي
قوات اجنبيه في العراق في حين يرى فريق
اخر انها او انها واقعيه وتستند لتفهمات
خارجيه ينبغي على العراق ان يسر بتجاهها
تحقيقا للاستقرار السياسي والامنيه
[موسيقى]
هناك هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من عمان
العراقي ومن بغداد وافق الجابري الباحث
السياسي اهلا بكم
ابدا من بغداد معك يا استاذ واثق في
الواقعه تصريحات محمد شويع السوداني رئيس
الوزراء العراقي هل تمثله لان بعض
الانتقادات من الاطار التنسيقي اتقول بان
هذه التصريحات تمثل شخص لا تمثل الاطار
ولا تمثل العراقين اين الحقيقه
نعم شكرا ستريم تحيه لكم مشاهديكم الكرام
والضيف الكريم طبيعه الحال
التواجد للقوات الامريكيه طبعا هو جاء
نتيجه اتفاق استراتيجي بين العراق
والولايات المتحده ويضمن الماده 28 ثانيا
اشارت ان ان هذه القوات الامريكيه يمكن
استدعاها في حال احتياج العراقي يعني بما
مضمونه او تعرض سيادته للانتهاك وبالتالي
تم استدعاء هذه القوات مره اخرى عام 2014
ضمن هذا الاتفاق لمحاربه جماعات داعش
والحرب مع داعش اعلن العراق بشكل رسمي ان
المعركه انتهت وانه انتصر على داعش وكل
العمليات التي تحدثت
حتى نتقدم بالزمن لانه التطورات متسارعه
في الواقع في العراق ومنذ سنوات قليله بعد
2014 كان هناك كذلك قرار اصدره البرلمان
العراقي واكد في وجوب اخلاء
وخروج القوات الاجنبيه نتحدث عن تصريح
السوداني تصريح السوداني هل يمثل همم شق
كبير من العراقيين حتى بعد اقرار البرلمان
بعكس ذلك
القرار الحكومي عدده يختلف عن الراي
السياسي في عند القوه السياسيه مختلفه
لذلك الحكومه عاده ما تتصرف او هي تتحدث
وفق رؤيه فنيه وهذه الرؤيه فنيه قد تاخذ
من خبراء عسكريه اضافه الى يعني همم
ممازجت هذا الراي مع ال- ال- الحاجه
السياسيه قد تكون الرؤيه العسكريه يعني او
ما تحدثت به القائد العسكريه للعراقيين ان
ال- ال- لا حاجه للقوات الامريكيه في
العراق ولا القوات العراقيه من قطار عصابه
داعش والعراق لا يحتاج سوى الى التسع يمكن
ان ياتي بالتسريح سواء كان من الولايات
المتحده او من غيرها
بان قادر ان يصرح وصافه هذه التصريحات
بالاراء الفنيه التي همم يمكن ان تاتيها
من السياسيين ولكن همم لا همم
تدعم او لا تعبر عن وجهه النظر العراقيه
ما رايك استاذ مهدي
لا هو هو المتراكمه
تفضل
نعم شكرا جزيلا لحضرتك ستريم
من بغداد علينا ان نبرز حقيقي مفادها ان
اتفاقيه الاطار ستراتيجي هي التي توجه
محرك العلاقه بين واشنطن واا بغداد واذا
ما عبرنا وتجاوزنا المراحل التي مرت بها
جولات الاتفاقيه همم عقد الكثير من
اللقاءات وتحولت من لقاءات الى همم الى
قرارات ومرورا بال 2008 او 2011 همم
اغتيال سليماني ومن ناتج من بعده قرار همم
البرلمان وصولا وهذه هي المرحله الاهم الى
استلام همم الاطار التنسيقي اداره تشكيل
الحكومه برئاسه السوداني وهنا هذا التحول
الكبير الذي حصل ما بعد مرحله ثلاثه رؤساء
امريكيين اوباما
يعني همم بايدن الان لم نرى مشاهد كثيره
لاستخدام المسيارات واستخدام لغه التهديد
المباشر وقصف السفاره الامريكيه هذا
التحول جاء من بعد
وصول الاطار التنسيقي بكل فصائله وايضا
بكل توجهات بعض الفصائل العقائديه
المرتبطه بايران هنا برغماتيه السياسه
انتهت ولا وجود ل- اا كانه همم عمق قديم
وكبير من السجالات وهمم من التهديدات
من الشعارات الكبيره
فقط
خروج القوات الاجنبيه من عدمها نحن يعني
الموضوع نقي لساعات طويله ولكن نحن في
حضور تصريحات لرئيس وزراء العراقي تتنافى
مع قرار البرلمان
واثاره الكثير من الجدل حول موقف الا
تنسيقي من هذا الحضور الاجنبي هذا السؤال
يعني كانت مقدمه للوصول الى السؤال اللي
حضرتك الان هناك
احتواء
دولي احتواء خليجي احتواء امريكي
لتنفيذ هذه
الاتفاقيه منها خليجي 45 خليج العربي خمسه
25 الذي اثار ايضا جدلا كبيرا تصريح
السوداني ونقمه ايران على هذا التصريح
ووصلت رسائلها كذلك الى همم السيد مقتدى
الصدر فهنا فاثار ايضا جدل هذا هذا التحول
في خطاب السداني اثار حفيظه بعض الشركاء
او ممن دفع السودان الى واجهه السلطه وهنا
ايضا حديث عن خلافات كبيره بين السودان
وبين الاطار همم التنسيق التمثل همم عدم
قبوله بتسلم او اداره الملفات الامنيه
لبعض الشخصيات وبعض الجهات
المنضويه تحت الاطار همم تنسيقي هذه وحده
من المشاكل ايضا الان هذا هات تصريح ربما
اثار حفيظه بعض الشخصيات زياره قاني الان
الى بغداد مع مع وجود من فوق البيت البيت
الابيض
حتى شخصيات وهناك حركه حقوق اعتقد تابعه
للاطار التنسيقي المنبثقه عن حزب الله
العراقي همم تحدثت عن همم مساعدها لمساءله
السوداني في هذا الاطار وقالت بان هناك
تحرك غير عادي ويجب ان يسال السيد محمد
همم سوداني عن الموضوع هل تعتقد سيد واسع
كما يرى ضيفي بان هذه التصريحات وما قاله
وما اشار لها همم لانه كانت هناك كذلك
تصريحات سابقه واعتبر فيها السوداني
الخليج خليج عربي ليس كما يسميه بعض
شخصيات لاطارتها بالخميس هل هناك تحول في
تصريحات السوداني وهناك بدايه ازمه بينه
وبين الاطار التنسيقي
لا هو ليس تحول في موقف للسيد السوداني
انا قلت براي رئيس الوزراء وينطلق من قبل
الايجار الفنيه ومن قبل
ويجمع كل مكونات الشعب العراقي باعتباره
لا يمثل مكونا او جهه سياسي بحذاته لكن
هذه القوه هي بنفسها ترى ان السيد
السوداني هو ممثلا للكتله الاكبر باعتبار
رايه من المفترض ان ينطلق من راي هذه
الكتله وهي الاطار التنسيق التالي بمفترض
ان يكون يعني خاضع لبرنامج هو توجهات همم
الاطار التنسيق واعتقد يعني هذا الجدول
والخلاف سوف يخضع للمناقشه باعتبار رئيس
الوزراء يعني هو في اجتماعات دوريه وهذه
اجتماعات يعني اسبوعيا وبالتالي يعني حتى
قوه الاطار انا اعتقد هنالك توجه الى
تهدئه الاوضاع واتباع الاساليب
الدبلوماسيه يعني حتى مع الولايات المتحده
لكن كما يبدو ان الولايات المتحده لم في
بعدها حتى مع سيد الكاظم حين ما زارها في
تموز عام 21 فتم الاتفاق على اجراء كل
القوات الامريكيه في نهايه همم عم 21 لحد
الان لم يطبق هذا القرار لذلك هذه القوه
هي متوجه سواء لا تعتقد ان لدى الولايات
المتحده مصداقيه يعني سوى وحده السيد
السوداني ام لم تعده او
ايا كان من الحلفاء وبالتالي هو هذا ما هو
الذي وجهه اختلاف او همم وجهه نظر مختلفه
داخل الاطار باعتبار الاطار هو ليست قوه
واحده وانها مجموعه من القوى السياسيه
استاذ مهدي هل ترك ضيفي بان ليس هناك تحول
في تصريحات السوداني اولا وبانا الموضوع
يمكن نمت وهو يمكن التوافق عليه همم داخل
الغرف مغلقه
يعني جميعنا يعلم ااا ان ااا علاقه ال-
ال- الكتل السياسيه فيما بينها حول رؤيه
واستراتيجيه العراق حول واشنطن ودول
المنطقه لديها تقاطعات كثيره السيد
السوداني لن يختلف كثيرا عن اي سياسات او
ستراتيجيات وضعت من قبل الحكومات السابقه
سواء حكومه الكاظميه التي بنت كثير من
العلاقات الخارجيه
العراقيه الاقليميه وبالتالي هناك مخاوف
من ان يذهب السوداني بعيدا همم بتطبيق مثل
هذه الملفات هذه الملفات اريد ان يوضع
السوداني في مجال الخنق في مجال الاحراج
من انه لا تذهب كثيرا في عمليه الهمم
العقود التي اؤمرت سواء في بغداد اثنين
وكذلك العلاقات استراتيجيه العلاقه بين
العراق
يعني احنا نعلم جيدا ان هناك الكثير من
الكتل السياسيه التي همم دعمت ودفعت همم
السوداني الى الواجهه لن ياتي من فراغ دون
ضوابط وبدون شروط منها علاقه همم الحكومه
العراقيه
بواشنطن العلاقات البرغماتيه الايرانيه في
مع بغداد دون المساس بها ضوابط كثيره وضعت
عند امام السوداني هذه الضوابط والمخاوف
من انه السودان قد يكسر مثل هذه همم
الجسور او هذه الاتفاقيات فبالتالي جاءت
هذه التحركات وما قلت قبل قليل زياره
القراني الى بغداد المفاجاه مع وصول مع
كورك البيت الابيض الى بغداد لتسير دعم
واشنطن اعلانيه الى حكومه السودان
الاتفاقيه التي ايضا قبل ايام مع ضعف ال-
الاهداف الانمائيه واعطاء منحى سنويا تقدر
ب 550 مليون دولار لحكومه السودان هذه
كلها مخاوف من انه ربما يجر او يسحب
البساط من قبل همم يعني الاطار التنسيقي
ومخافه على بعض استحقاقات التي ربما تعهد
و- اا السوداني بتنفيذها هذه جميعها مخاوف
وهم الاطار التنسيقي اا بايقاف السوداني
او تحجيما او همم يعني محاوله حصره في
دائره همم دائره السياسات المؤثره
الداخليه والخارجيه على القرار السياسي
همم العراقي السوداني لن يكون بعيدا عن
تنفيذ ما تم الاتفاق عليه بين العراق
وبغداد ولا تستطيع اي قوى داخليه ان تؤثر
على نوعيه العلاقه بين واشنطن وبين بغداد
والمشروع همم الامريكي المتبانات اضافه
الى الانفتاح اليوم الذي نشهده العراق على
دول الاقليم والدول الاقليم كذلك نقاط
بخصوص هذا الانفتاح البعض يقول بانه همم
ما هو انفتاح مرحله ولكن قد تقيده بعض
المواقف المنتظره في القريب العاجل خاصه
وان السوداني لم يصرح بما اتينا عليه فقط
وانما تحدث كذلك عن تشديد العلاقه وتمتين
العلاقه مع الجانب الامريكي وفي هذا
الاطار استاذ واثق هل يمكن للسوداني ان
يكسر وان يضرب بعرض الحائط بعض التقاليد
همم موجوده داخل اطار التنسيقي وان يغير
البوصله الى اتجاهات الاخرى
لا هو الان يعني لا اعتقد يعني هو يعني
سيذهب بعيدا يعني عن توجهات الاطار
التنسيق لكن هو ربما قد يقرب بوجات النظر
يعني الان اعتقد يعني هو حتى قوه الاطار
والسيد السوداني الكل متجهه على بناء
علاقات اقليميه رصيد اكثر من ما هو التوجه
باعتبار اليوم بوصل العالميه تغيرت يعني
الصيام بعد الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه لذلك
تجدين الان اكثر القوه الداعمه للتقارب
العربي العربي بالذات يعني الان يعني
للحظه او من خليجي 25 يعني القوه الاطار
هي بكل اعلامها ويدعمها وكل تحركاتها بدعم
كل هذا التقارب العربي وخلق نوع من
الاجواء السياسيه المدعمده من هذا الاساس
يفضل لك السيد السوداني وحتى هو الاطار
اولا يعني من ال ال من الداخل العراقي ومن
المنطقه الاقليميه باتجاه العالم باعتبار
ان العالم اليوم ليست فقط هي الولايات
المتحده القوه الوحيده والم مركبه في
العالم وان ما هنالك قوه اخرى منافسه وهي
تستطيع ان تكون هي ربما تكون بديله يعني
في المنطقه والدول العربيه الان ايضا بدات
ترى هكذا وبالتالي
العلاقات مع حكومه بطبيعه النقاشات وطبيعه
تقريبا يعني الشرح المفصل من قبل السيد
السوداني نعم نعم
العراقي شكرا لكم